and quickly and ended 141 126 after the
game
kyrie the former celtic
planting that foot on the leprechaun's
face
and then somebody in the stands throws a
water bottle
and that came very close
to connecting i don't even think the two
incidents
are connected where he saw that no i'm
not saying i'm not saying that
i mean there's a connection but you're
saying kyrie irving playing in boston
and as he leaves the floor there goes
the water bottle
and uh there goes authorities have their
man
and he did have a good point earlier
kenny he's handcuffed well i said
he let take that kid downstairs and like
kyrie howard used to
well might beat the hell out of kyrie no
i didn't see it she did yeah
yes you did kids deandre jordan
man up here don't
don't be scared by the way td garden
issuing a lifetime
ban that's what they should do at any
time
all right let's hear from uh kd and
kyrie on the incident
fans got to grow up at some point i know
that being in the house for a year and a
half
with the pandemic we got a lot of people
on edge
got a lot of people who are stressed out
but when you come to these games you got
to realize man these
these these men are human you know we're
not animals we're not in the circus
uh you coming to the game it's not all
about you as a fan so have some respect
for the game have some respect for these
human beings
and have some respect for yourself your
mother wouldn't be uh proud of you
throwing water bottles at
basketball players or spitting on
players or tossing popcorn so
go uh and enjoy the game
people just feel very entitled out here
you know they pay for the tickets great
i'm grateful that
for coming in to watch um a great
performance but it's just
you know we're not at the theater we're
not throwing tomatoes and other
random stuff at the people that are
performing you know it's just
it's too much and it's a reflection on
um
you know us as a whole when you have
fans acting like that we know how these
people here are in boston
and we know how passionate they are
about kyrie in particular
um and they still upset at him
and that's no reason for them to act
childish but
we don't need to speak on that we know
what it is already coming in here
glad we got the w hopefully we don't got
to come back here this year
and we know the vast vast majority of
nba fans and sports
fans are just that they're sports oh
yeah it was 17
000 people in there yeah 16 999 acted
accordingly yeah and that one acted you
know so it's not it's not a percentage
but but i also think that these now it's
getting to the point where
they feel that they're going to get on
sportscenter they're going to get on tnt
they're going to inside the nba
i think some of that is accurate as well
and that behavior
like wanting to be seen you know do you
think he did that wanting to be
i think i think he's wanting to want to
get arrested stop it no he wants to be
seen these people
he got arrested kenny the criminal mind
is illogical from the start
so anytime you do something that's
criminal it's illogical so
kenny do things because they want
attention well yeah like
yeah like i can see that if a guy runs
on the field at a football game or does
something like this
was stupid and this yeah listen i think
we have to don't go
crazy we've had i think four incidents
and we've had hundreds of thousands of
fans there's always there's always been
fans that were idiots
but the majority of the fans are good
people like you say
one guy out of 17 000 acting like an
idiot tonight yeah but don't act like
this this
is just not this thing look i play how
long you play
16. i played 19 years i've seen that
before i played i played in the sec i've
seen it before
i played high school basketball in texas
i've seen it before and both guys
make good points you know a lot of these
parents feel just because they pay money
they can save whatever they want and do
whatever they want but i'm in a position
look it happens it's been happening for
a long time the water bottle didn't hit
them
let's just move on thank you because
guess what it's going to continue to
happen
well let's hope not oh that's going to
happen ernie ernie
ernie shaq all right sacramento always
happens
it happens it happened when me and shaq
play
and it's going to happen there's always
going to be idiot fans
bring on stuff okay i'm a little more
hopeful anyway